>>> TONIGHT, FORMER PRESIDENT
TRUMP IS LASHING OUT AT
WOODWARD FOR RELEASING EIGHT
HOURS OF RAW AUDIO FROM 20
INTERVIEWS HE RECORDED WITH
TRUMP FOR HIS NEW AUDIO BOOK.
BOB WOODWARD IS TANDING BY LIVE.
WE'LL DISCUSS IN A FEW MOMENT.
BUT HERE IS TOM FOREMAN WITH
MORE ON THE VERY REVEALING
TAPES.
>> MR. WOODWARD, THE PRESIDENT.
>> HI, BOB.
>> Reporter: THE CALLS CAME AT
ALL HOURS ON ALL SUBJECTS.
>> NOBODY IS TOUGHER THAN ME.
YOU ASKED ME ABOUT IMPEACHMENT
AND YOU ACT LIKE YOU JUST WON
THE TUCKING RACE.
>> SOMETIMES BRAGGING.
>> I HAVE A REPUTATION OF NOT
WILLING TO APOLOGIZE.
I WILL APOLOGIZE IF I'M WRONG.
>> WHEN WAS LAST TIME YOU
APOLOGIZED.
>> I DON'T KNOW.
OVER A PERIOD OF TIME -- HERE IS
THE THING.
I'M NEVER WRONG, OKAY.
>> Reporter: THEN RELAXED AND
ENTERTAINING AND OCCASIONALLY
ALARMING.
>> I HAVE BUILT A WEAPON SYSTEM
THAT NOBODY HAS EVER WILL IN
THIS COUNTRY BEFORE.
WE HAVE STUFF THAT YOU HAVEN'T
EVEN SEEN OR HEARD BEFORE.
WE STUFF THAT PUTIN AND XI HAVE
NEVER HEARD ABOUT BEFORE.
>> Reporter: JUST AS HE HAS IN
PUBLIC, TRUMP PRAISED THE
RUSSIAN PRESIDENT.
>> RESPECT PUTIN AND I THINK HE
LIKES ME.
>> Reporter: BUT HE WAS EQUALLY
AFUSIVE ABOUT THE NORTH KOREA
LEADER.
>> THE CIA SAID ABOUT KIM
JONG-UN THAT HE'S CUNNING AND
CRAFTY AND ULTIMATELY STUPID.
>> I DISAGREE.
HE'S CUNNING AND CRAFTY AND HE'S
A VERY SMART BEEN.
>> HOW DOES THE CIA SAY THAT.
>> BECAUSE THEY DON'T KNOW,
OKAY.
BECAUSE THEY DON'T KNOW.
THEY HAVE NO IDEA.
I'M THE ONLY ONE THAT KNOWS.
>> Reporter: AS FOR THE DANGER
OF KIM LAUNCHING MISSILES AT THE
U.S. OR AMERICAN ALLIES.
>> IF HE SHOOTS.
HE SHOOTS.
HE'S GOT BIG, BIG PROBLEMS.
>> Reporter: UNDER IT ALL
TRUMP'S FAITH IN HIS ABILITY TO
JUDGE PEOPLE.
>> THE WORD CHEMISTRY.
YOU MEET SOMEBODY AND YOU HAVE A
GOOD CHEMISTRY.
YOU MEET A WOMAN AND IN ONE
SECOND YOU KNOW WHETHER OR NOT
IT IS ALL GOING TO HAPPEN.
>> Reporter: TRUMP WENT ON AT
LENGTH ABOUT HIS POWER,
POPULARITY WITH HIS BASE AND
ABILITY TO RUN RINGS AROUND
OLD WASHINGTON.
>> THERE HAS NEVER BEEN
FUNDRAISING LIKE I'M DOING.
>> Reporter: ABOUT THE COVID-19
PANDEMIC AND A CONVERSATION
ABOUT IT WITH HIS YOUNGEST SON.
>> HE WAS 13 AND IN THE WHITE
HOUSE UPSTAIRS IN HIS BEDROOM.
HE SAID, DAD WHAT IS GOING ON.
AND I SAID IT CAME OUT OF CHINA.
PURE AND SIMPLE, IT CAME OUT OF
CHILDREN AND IT SHOULD HAVE BEEN
STOPPED AND TO BE HONEST WITH
YOU, BARREN, THEY HAVE LET US
KNOW IF WAS A PROBLEM TWO MONTHS
EARLIER AND THE WORLD -- WE HAVE
141 COUNTRIES HAVE IT NOW.
AND I SAID THE WORLD WOULDN'T
HAVE A PROBLEM.
WE COULD HAVE STOPPED IT EASILY.
>> Reporter: BUT THERE WAS ONE
TOPIC THAT SEEMED TO STOP HIM.
AT THE TIME THE UPCOMING 2020
ELECTION AND HIS REAL CHANCE OF
LOSING.
AS HE DID.
>> EVERYONE SAID TRUMP IS GOING
TO STAY IN THE WHITE HOUSE IF
ITS CONTESTED.
>> WELL I DON'T WANT TO EVEN
COMMENT ON THAT.
>> SURE.
>> I DON'T WANT TO COMMENT ON
THAT AT THIS TIME.
I'LL TALK TO YOU LATER ON
TONIGHT.
>> Reporter: WITH ALL OF THIS
SIT HITTING THE SOUTH, HE JUMPED
ON TRUTH SOCIAL AND BOB NEVER
WERE ALLOWED FOR PURPOSES OF
MAKING SURE THAT HE GOT MY
QUOTES AND STATEMENTS CORRECT.
HE AND HIS PUBLISHER HAD NO
RIGHT TO USE MY VOICE OR THEM.
THAT IS WHAT HE IS SAYING
PUBLICLY.
BUT AS WE KNOW, THE PRESIDENT
OFTEN COMPLAINS ABOUT THESE
PUBLICLY BUT PRIVATELY STILL
LIKES THE ATTENTION.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>>> LET'S DISCUSS ALL OF THIS
WITH THE LEGENDARY JOURNALIST
HIMSELF, THE AUTHOR OF THE NEW
AUDIO BOOK, THE TRUMP TAPES.
BOB WOODWARD, THANKS SO MUCH FOR
JOINING US.
>> THANK YOU.
>> LET ME GET YOUR RESPONSE,
YOUR REACTION TO WHAT THE FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID, HE CLAIMED
YOU NEVER GOT HIS PERMISSION TO
RELEASE THESE TAPES.
HOW DO YOU RESPOND TO THAT?
>> WELL, THEY WERE DONE
VOLUNTARILY.
IT WAS ALL ON THE RECORD.
I HAD USED SOME OF IT BEFORE, SO
HE'S PRESIDENT AND HE'S -- AND
HE'S NOT SOMEBODY WHO IS -- HE'S
SO OUT THERE.
AND THIS IS OUT THERE TO THE
TENTH POWER.
AND IT, TO ME, IT WAS REVEALING
WHEN I WENT BACK AND LISTENED TO
IT.
THAT YOU SEE HIS SELF
ASSESSMENTS ARE JUST OFF AND
DANGEROUS.
ON FOREIGN AFFAIRS, IT IS ALL
ABOUT CHEMISTRY AND HIS
INSTINCT.
WELL, OF COURSE, THIS DROVE HIS
NATIONAL SECURITY TEAM CRAZY.
TRAUMATIZED THEM.
ON THE ECONOMY, HE SAID
REPEATEDLY, I BUILT THE BIGGEST
AND BEST ECONOMY IN THE WORLD.
WELL, HE HAD TO A GOOD ECONOMY,
HE WAS HANDED A PRETTY GOOD ONE
BY OBAMA.
ON RACE RELATIONS, HE SAID THAT
HE'S DONE MORE FOR BLACK PEOPLE
THAN ANY PRESIDENT OTHER THAN
ABRAHAM LINCOLN.
HE GIVES A TOP BILLING TO
LINCOLN.
BUT HE GIVES HIMSELF SECONDARY
BILLING AND I'VE RAISED, WELL
HOW ABOUT LYNDON JOHNSON.
NO, NO.
TRUMP DID MORE THAN ANYONE OTHER
THAN ABE LINCOLN.
SO, YOU KNOW, THIS IDEA THAT
HE'S TOUGHER, THIS -- THE WHOLE
PRESENTATION OF THE
UNDERSTANDING HE HAS OF HIMSELF
IS OFF THE MARK.
UNSUPPORTED BY EVIDENCE.
IT IS -- AND THEN YOU LISTEN TO
IT, AND YOU HEAR THE CENTER, THE
DRIVE, YOU KNOW, YOU PLAYED
ABOUT -- I ASKED, HAVE YOU EVER
APOLOGIZED.
WELL MY REPUTATION IS TO NEVER
APOLOGIZE.
I'M NOT GOING TO -- THIS IS
ABOUT IMPEACHMENT.
I SAID WHY NOT JUST SAY THIS
CALL WITH UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT
ZELENSKYY WAS SOMETHING THAT HAS
BEEN MISINTERPRETED OR WHATEVER.
NO, NO.
IT IS A PERFECT CALL.
AND I SPENT 15 MINUTES
INTERROGATING HIM DOWN IN
MAR-A-LAGO AND HE COULD JUST NOT
GIVE.
HE WOULD AVOID THE PLAIN
LANGUAGE OF THAT CALL.
>> AND HE WOULD OFTEN JUST CALL
YOU, YOU DIDN'T EVEN INITIATE
ALL OF THE CALLS.
THE NEW AUDIO THAT YOU JUST
RELEASES, TRUMP SEEMS TO LAUGH
ABOUT HIS INABILITY TO ACTUALLY
APOLOGIZE.
LET'S TAKE A LISTEN ONCE AGAIN.
LISTEN TO THIS.
>> I HAVE THIS REPUTATION OF NOT
BEING WILLING TO APOLOGIZE.
IT IS WRONG.
I WILL APOLOGIZE.
IF I'M WRONG.
THIS CONVERSATION --
>> WHEN WAS LAST TIME YOU
APOLOGIZED.
>> I DON'T KNOW.
I THINK OVER A PERIOD.
HERE IS THE THING.
I'M NEVER WRONG.
OKAY.
>> BUT LET ME ASK YOU THIS, DID
HE EVER SERIOUSLY REFLECT ON HIS
CHARACTER FLAWS?
>> WELL, NOT REALLY.
I ASKED HIM WHAT GRADE HE WOULD
GIVE HIMSELF ON THE HANDLING OF
THE CORONAVIRUS AND HE SAID OH,
HE'D GIVE HIMSELF A VERY HIGH
GRADE.
WHEN IN THE CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
THE VIRUS WITH HIM, HE WILL SAY
AND SAYS, YOU COULD HEAR HIM, WE
HAVE IT UNDER CONTROL.
WE HAVE IT UNDER CONTROL.
140,000 PEOPLE HAD DIED AT THAT
POINT.
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE THAT HE HAS
IT UNDER CONTROL.
IT IS NOW COMING OUT MORE I
FOUND OUT THAT DR. FAUCI AND THE
EXPERTS WERE HORRIFIED AT THE
WAY TRUMP WOULD NOT LISTEN TO
THEM, WOULD JUST DISMISS THEM.
SO FINALLY AT ONE POINT I TALKED
TO FAUCI AND ALL OF THE OTHER
EXPERTS AND I SAID, WHAT SHOULD
HE BE DOING?
AND THEY GAVE ME A LIST OF ABOUT
12 OR 16 THINGS.
LIKE COORDINATE WITH THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY, AND IT
WAS -- IT WAS SO -- IT IS LIKE
HE WAS FROZEN IN THE JOB.
>> WE'RE ALL GRATEFUL TO YOU,
BOB WOODWARD, FOR RELEASING THE
AUDIO TAPE